Hands down, if you only got one thing that you're going to do,
it has to be home visits.
Home visits by far just makes it so that you have a more trusting relationship,
you have a good foundation to build a relationship off of,
and you can move forward from there in many different ways.
My teachers are focused on one-on-ones at home-- go into the community,
meet your families, talk to them about your hopes and dreams.
Just ask them, what do they want for their kids?
And parents usually don't hear that question,
and they definitely don't hear it from anybody
that has dc.gov at the end of their email address.
We assume we know how parents get information.
And through home visits, I know now how parents get information,
and it's not always through a newsletter,
and it's not always through a calendar.
That first year, I remember trying to do home visits was like pulling teeth.
We were tracking parents down, and they did not want us to come to their house.
You know, they saw us as, why do you want to come to the house?
What are they looking for, you know?
They didn't trust us.
I was against it at first, until they explained
that we're not here to call CPS.
We just want to get to know the child, what you expect from us,
and what we expect from you.
I said, well, why can't we do that at school?
And they said, well, this is something new that we're trying.
But when they had it, I enjoyed it.
It's to get to know the teacher on a personal level,
to find out his background or her background, or what school she went to,
or how she got her education, or how he got his education.
So I loved it.
Now they're looking for me.
Where's my home visit, Ms. McKay?
When are you coming?
When are you coming to the house?
It's just a very different feel, and I think
a lot of that was just establishing that trust with parents.
I went to one of the communities this past August
to do some of my home visits.
And I brought a newer staff member with me, who was a little nervous
and had never done it before.
And, you know, it's a little bit of an area
that you might not feel comfortable in necessarily
by yourself if you hadn't been there before.
And we're walking.
We're walking, and this man's walking up to me.
And she looks nervous.
And he's like, you Ms. McKay, aren't you?
And I was like, yeah, I am.
And he was like, you taught my nephew whatever, whatever.
And I was like, oh yeah.
You know, we're talking for a little bit.
And then I'm walking through the courtyard,
and I hear my name coming from different houses, because the kids know you.
They know your face.
And even if you didn't teach them, you may
have taught their friend, or their brother, or their sister.
I love going on home visits.
I love engaging with the families.
It's just you're sitting there, holding a baby on your lap,
and talking about this and that.
You know, they're offering you food, and it's just-- yeah,
it's definitely worth it.
The family visits, I love them because they ask questions like, you know,
what are their strengths, their weaknesses,
and how can they help to make them stronger in the class
or in a certain subject.
So it's really-- I love the home visits
I'm going to come to your house.
I'm going to sit down.
I'm going to drink your tea and I'm going
to talk about your kid and their hopes and dreams, right?
And I'm going to listen to your expectations, because, you know,
parents expect us to do stuff too as teachers.
It doesn't just go we, we, we, we expect you, you, you, you
to do all this stuff, right?
It's a two-way street.
It gives you more of a stake in that family.
And because you're invested in them, they're
going to be more invested in you.
That in itself was very new for parents.
And they're like, oh, we like that.
Somebody actually asking me what I want for my kid?
I feel like I'm an equal partner in this relationship.
Like, oh, I like that.
Ms. Bryant goes around there, honey.
She goes to them kids house she ain't scared of nothing or nobody.
Ms. Bryant walks the neighborhood.
She comes around there, she played with the kids, she jumped rope,
she goes to the ice cream truck.
She do it all for them kids.
It was very interesting to just sit there, and just lay back, and just
have a-- like it's your brother, or your,
sister, or your family member just sitting
there holding a whole conversation.
And to be honest with you, they felt like they were at home.
So when you have a person that feel like they at home, it's the best thing.